Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in authored by
in the chapter
regarding
vigilance
of Allah's observation subhanahu wa
ta'ala
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has informed us in his book
of decree
and he has likewise has informed us of
free will. The human being has free
will. The human being has decree. What
is the extent of each of those?
As we've mentioned before,
previous
groups,
previous nations,
entire religions have fallen to
misguidance
with respect to the issue
of free will and the issue of decree and
destiny.
There are some that are so
aggressive in affirming
decree and destiny,
so
extreme in their affirmation of
destiny that free will is all but
non-existent.
And then there are the opposites,
their counterparts
which
have so extremely
so extremely
affirmed
free will to the point where there is no
destiny in these people's minds.
Now the Muslim
who reads the Quran,
who reads the Sunnah, the educated
Muslim, the Muslim who learns from Allah
and his messenger and the companions of
the messenger of Allah, will they
understand
decree in all of its detail?
No.
Not even a scholar,
not even
a messenger would understand
everything with respect to the decree of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And for this reason it's said by the
scholarship of Islam
that
that decree it's one of the secrets of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam warned us
of trying to understand and get to the
bottom of every single detail of decree.
And if decree has is mentioned then
refrain from discussing it in great
detail without knowledge and debating
and affirming or negating without
knowledge of decree.
The human being has free will.
The human being is also destined by
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. The human
being has destiny. Allah wrote all that
is to be. He knew and then he wrote and
then he willed and then he created.
And within those parameters, the human
being has been endowed with free will
that he or she can exercise to its
limits within those parameters. This is
what Allah teaches us in the Quran.
That's that's how he teaches us. He
teaches us what is the extent of the
decree of Allah. Has Allah forced us to
do anything? No. But he decrees.
And what is the extent of our endowment
with free will that it is
limited by our finite existent, the
finite choices presented to us in our
existence and that which would negate
decree. So we walk a middle path. How
does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala say that?
He sums it up so easily, so beautifully.
And these are the kinds of truisms or
the kinds of proverbs that we should
teach our children. And that is
and you all do not will something
except
that after Allah has willed it. You may
not will, you may not exercise your free
will unless Allah permits you to do so.
Unless Allah wills for you to
exercise your will. Right? That's the
middle path. Does he explain to us the
every detail? No.
But he tells us the amount that we need
to know in order to be healthy in our
belief and affirmation of both sides.
This is what he is teaching Abdullahb
Abbas in this narration that we've been
dealing with. And this is probably
what's the fourth or fifth day that
we've discussed this narration. And we
could discuss it for another five days
easily.
We could probably discuss it for another
five weeks
if we were to follow up all of the
meanings and insinuations and all of
the implications of these this
narration. However, each of these
statements, each of these sentences is a
proverb that the Muslim is to memorize
and to implement in his life. Whenever
he is faced at a crossroads, he
remembers these proverbs. He remembers
these truisms. He remembers what we
say these sayings, right? He remembers
these sayings. when I say for
instance better safe than
sorry right how many decisions have you
or I made based on that statement it's a
correct statement the statement is
correct it's it's very wise right better
safe than sorry right don't count your
chickens before they you have you guys
have that one over here hatch yeah don't
count your chickens before they hatch
Right. or you know, do you guys
know any others that
don't put all your eggs in one basket,
right? There's another one. How many
decisions have we made in our lives
remembering
the
the wisdom imparted by these proverbs
or these truisms right many
decisions now these
are the proverbs the truisms that the
prophet teaches us
and you see you don't have to argue
argue the meanings of these proverbs
and find evidence for them. if I
say don't count your chickens before
they hatch, right?
I don't have to have evidence and and
logically explain this to my child when
I say this saying. I say it, he
memorizes it, right? If he wants to
explore it later, he can. This is how we
teach our children. What are some
Islamic
proverbs?
So for instance,
that is one, right?
There's another one, right?
Right.
These are proverbs that we teach our
children when they come to a crossroads.
They are able to refer back to these
statements and make the proper
decisions. Abbass
Abbass his
Abbass. Yeah. And how is he related
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam?
Huh? His cousin. Yes. He's his first
cousin from his father's side. So
paternal cousin. Correct. And what
year did he pass away?
50 58 after hij right the difference the
historians often differ in that but
the correct opinion inshallah is that he
passed away in the year 58 after hijra
I abb says that he was riding behind the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam one
day and he said to me young boy, I'm
going to teach you some words of wisdom,
some statements, some proverbs, some
truisms. Then he gave that him
sentences
short sentences that he could easily
memorize.
He says in in these sentences to finish
up this narration,
preserve Allah's boundaries and you will
find him
before you. You will find him in front
of you wherever
you need him or call out to him.
Get to know Allah. Build a relationship
with him in times of ease and he will
recognize you in your times of
difficulty.
And know
that
whatever
has missed you
was never meant to have afflicted you.
And whatever afflicts you was never
meant to have missed you. The concept of
a close call, that's for us, right?
If if I were to look at that door
and see the clearance between the door
and the door jamb,
say, "Wow, the door misses the door jamb
by just fraction of an inch." To me,
if the door is beyond my understanding,
that could be coincidence.
But to the person who designed that
door, that was intentional the whole
time. It was never meant to It was never
meant to bump into the door jam. We
couldn't say
it is so close. Just a little bit
longer. It would have. No, it never
could have. It could have never been
designed to not close because it was
designed. It was made. It was willed to
be exactly that size, to fit in exactly
that door and exactly that door jamb.
And so to us,
we we call things coincidence.
We call things coincidence, close call,
near miss, almost.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he sees
things as will to have happened or not.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. He says
and know
that victory comes only with patience.
And know
that relief only comes with difficulty.
Relief only comes with its crisis.
And know that with every difficulty
comes ease.
these things. It doesn't just mean that
the more patient you are, the closer you
are to victory,
the more patient you are and hopeful you
are, the closer you are to relief
doesn't just mean that, but it also
means that what is the concept of of
victory without patience?
It doesn't exist.
That is the very definition of victory.
And so the companions,
they understood from these statements
that
the more difficult a situation would get
and the longer it would linger,
the greater the relief was going to be
when it came.
and that every day that passed, they
were always a day closer to the day of
relief and victory. And relief cannot be
experienced without being preceded with
with difficulty. Otherwise, what is
relief? It has no meaning. Just a
sunny day has no meaning without a rainy
one. Just pleasure has no meaning
without pain. These things are two sides
of the same coin. Just like
winter and summer, life and death. What
gives our lives meaning right now?
What gives our life meaning? Is it not
that we're going to die? And so we have
to work in that time. Doesn't that
get us out of bed? Doesn't that you
know, I'm getting old. I'm getting this
right meaning person is drawing closer
to death and so this is a motivation in
their life that is what gives us meaning
if we were going to be eternally living
here on this earth what would the
meaning to that be
nothing
subhanahu waala and
and
subhanahua
[Silence]
How's your day?